brace for impact tomorrow morning the
Muller report will be released and
Muller madness begins our sources
telling us tonight
minimal redactions the American people
will see this and still the media mob
Democrats Trump haters everywhere will
get their one last itsy-bitsy chance to
breathlessly hysterically hyperventilate
over nothing a baseless a vengeful hoax
a Russia collusion witch-hunt that has
come up totally and completely and
utterly empty no collusion no conspiracy
no construction now no matter what
sentences paragraphs pages Democrats the
mob and the media fixate on none of the
changes the outcome we already know the
outcome if you go to Vegas you can bet
on what I'm telling you four separate
investigations now have cleared Donald
Trump and the Trump campaign including
the also powerful special counsel filled
with investigators who are almost all of
them big-time Democratic donors
supporters of Hillary even somebody who
went to her victory party and a former
lawyer of Hillary after 22 months 2,800
subpoenas 500 search warrants 230 court
orders interviews with approximately 500
people the Muller report this is
directly from the report concluded quote
the investigation did not establish that
members of the Trump campaign conspired
or coordinated with the Russian
government in its election interference
activities which by the way Devon Nunez
warned us about in 2014 no one inside
the Trump campaign that means Donald
Trump conspired or coordinated with the
Russian government no one that is now
fact two and a half years you've had
your tinfoil hat conspiracy theories
your daily lies in the media mob the
Democratic Party working in unison in
one voice to slander smear besmirch and
destroy a duly elected president and
everybody around him they have for two
and a half years flat-out lied to you we
the American people over
and over and over again and we've got
the proof let's take a little trip down
well memorably memory witch-hunt Lane
take a look we're about to find out if
the new president of our country is
going to do what Russia wants as if
there are no shoes on the Trump Human
Centipede
that are not about Russia Russia Russia
Russia this cloud about collusion with
Russia will hang over him no matter
where he stands he may be the first
president in quite some time to face the
real prospect of jail time I think
they're shocked that the noose is
tightening it's clear that mother is now
connecting the dots between a massive
obstruction intended to hide the truth
this president needs to be impeached I
believe that I believe there was
collusion Donald Trump's done he's done
there's no question about he's got to
know his future looks like it's behind
bars we have a treasonous president we
now have to figure out how to deal with
a President of the United States who
wittingly or unwittingly has been
compromised this is not funny this is
really bad just for the record we're all
really nervous the beginning of the end
of the Trump presidency you could feel
the thread being pulled you can feel the
clothes starting to come off the emperor
I believe this is the beginning of the
end
the president sees the walls closing in
and his lashing out he's desperate he's
obviously flailing around because he
feels the walls closing in he feels the
walls closing in on him the president's
done everything he can in trashing the
special counsel mr. Trump is seeing more
and more of the walls closing in on him
which is why he is becoming increasingly
desperate what if he refuses to open the
White House door what if the secret you
know will the kid what if he fires any
Secret Service agent who would allow the
federal marshals in what if Donald Trump
simply decides I don't have to follow
the law I refuse to be held under the
law no marshal can get into this White
House the presidency is effectively a
Russian op all right you know partisan
warfare between Republicans and
Democrats this is international warfare
against our country
they were all psychotic they've all lost
it they've all lied can anyone ever
really believe the collusion truther
rachel maddow ever again
she and all these others conning their
viewers and by the way many for a lot of
financial gain tomorrow they will give
it their one last college try good luck
and you can expect more of what you just
saw on steroids and human growth hormone
but it is officially the media mob the
Democratic Party's last chance to revive
their favorite psychotic conspiracy
theories they still don't know it's done
it's over they lost again it's election
night all over again 2016 and here's the
sad reality
they'll never apologize they won't
retract false reports retract their
politically motivated daily hysteria
they're breathless Russia Russia Russia
impeach impeaching Beach collusion
collusion collusion insanity never
you'll never own up to being a part of
the biggest most dangerous fraud
conspiracy theory ever perpetrated
against we the American people and when
they finally realize they lost and they
did and they lied and they did and they
failed on a spectacular level and they
did they just gonna move on to the next
slide and then the next slide and then
the next conspiracy theory and they're
gonna act as if this never happened bad
dream hope you forgot as I've said
mainstream media so-called journalism is
dead in America and the fools who claim
to have a monopoly of facts they don't
want to report Muller's key findings let
me go back from the Muller report the
investigation did not establish that
members of the Trump campaign conspired
or coordinated with the Russian
government in its election interference
activities Muller's words not Hannity a
direct quote from the Muller report an
undeniable irrefutable fact this is the
paragraph that the liars on the Left can
barely bring themselves to acknowledge
but with the fake collusion narrative
dead and buried you can already see the
mob switching their narrative oh well
maybe we'll get them on obstruction we
need Trump's tax returns we need to oh
well have a memory
of understanding and we'll all agree to
go after him on this now get this
obstruction of justice from a crime that
was never committed
how can you obstruct without the
underlying crime and by the way with the
statute of obstruction you need intent
that is required by law when one has
consistently and repeatedly repeatedly
and loudly like the president rightly
proclaiming his innocence he acted the
way innocent people act they're outraged
so of course the president was never
charged with obstruction
not by Muller not by the attorney
general's office not even uncle rod
Rosenstein and tomorrow in the report
you might see information about well the
president he fired Jim Comey yeah that's
not obstruction even Comey pointed out
the president can fire an FBI director
for any reason or no reason at all and
you might hear and they're gonna hang on
to evidence about well the president
talked about firing rod Rosenstein and
other officials like he won't he talked
about firing Muller himself or the
president wished a 33-year veteran a
hero who served this country in combat
general Flynn would not get in trouble
president talked about this is
ridiculous I hope he doesn't get in
trouble but guess what the president
never fired Rosenstein never fired
Muller never fired sessions never fired
any of the Democrats hired to sustain
the witch-hunt he never stopped the
investigation in other words he never
impeded he never obstructed he didn't
impede against the case against
lieutenant general Flynn or any other
target of this witch-hunt and shouting
from a rooftop that you're innocent as
the president has that you're a victim
of a witch hunt that's not a crime
expressing frustration about injustice
is not obstruction talking is not
obstruction thinking about something is
not obstruction it's kind of like well
like rod Rosenstein another deep state
rats
talking about wearing a wire because
they wanted a spy on the president or
conspiring and talking about using the
25th amendment to remove the president
from office now there are officials
right now in the are DOJ right now they
actually had those real conversations
but none of them are
charged with the crime because they
didn't act they didn't commit one in
this case
well maybe others did though which we're
gonna get to in this case well they
didn't wear the wire they didn't use the
25th amendment they never acted they
talked about it talking's not a crime
now if the Democrats the hate Trump
media mob if they really cared about
obstruction and when you hear these
people tomorrow okay I got a great case
for them why oh why oh why did they
ignore the blatant obstruction of
justice committed by one of their own
their favorite candidate Hillary Clinton
now we know she violated the Espionage
Act it's a fact she stored classified
top-secret information on an unsecured
server here is the law irrefutable you
can see it right there
incontrovertible and overwhelming
evidence even Comey admitted she did
this then she deleted 33,000 subpoenaed
emails washed the hard drive with bleach
pit removed the SIM cards had an aide
destroy her devices with hammers just in
case those emails were still on there
now the media mob that will be so
outraged over obstruction tomorrow this
was the biggest slam dunk obstruction
case ever it had an underlying crime and
intent the intent in this case destroy
the evidence of the crime more media
more liberal selectively phony moral
outrage that's what you'll see tomorrow
remember in the Kavanaugh case oh they
were able Eve I believe where are the I
believers because we have serious
allegations of rape and violent sexual
assault
right now against the Democratic
lieutenant governor of Virginia all the
I believers are quiet now we saw with
the covet in high school kids they are
they rushed the jet that didn't even
slander a 16 year old kid we see it with
climate change we see it with their new
green deal and socialist policies and by
the way Hillary was never charged with
her crime because her investigation
which we now know was rigged by the deep
state just the upper echelon not rank
and file and that's why Lindsey Graham
senator from South Carolina is now
rightly investigating the investigation
into the Clinton email scandal and in
case the evidence is overwhelming and
incontrovertible it's now crystal clear
we on this show and we have this
ensemble cast radio and TV staffs the
people you see all for the last two
years we've been right all along the
Clinton investigation was fixed in her
favor by a few high-ranking government
bureaucrats who wanted her to be
president wanted Trump to lose a
president Trump faced a modern-day
political persecution at the hands of
those very same people the same people
that gave her a pass rigged her
investigation
if the deep state was really concerned
about collusion and why is there no
investigation into collusion we now know
Ukraine is begging to give them evidence
they're admitting they colluded to help
Hillary in the 2016 election thanks to
John Solomon we also know Ukrainian
government official did this is
admitting this it has evidence to this
fact to impact the 2016 election so as
robert muller going to be reappointed to
investigate the clinton campaign and
only hire republican donors and what
about clinton's bought and paid for
dossier he had the dossier with of all
things imagine this russian government
lies misinformation propaganda now
debunked now tonight according to
Politico we're learning that the DoD DOJ
inspector general's report will likely
target the author of the dossier
Christopher Steele that's fine but the
real focus mr. inspector general should
be on the person that paid for that
lying dossier those that never verified
that dossier and committed a fraud on
the FISA Court those that leaked the
information in that dossier to their
friends in the media so they leaked it
before the election to influence the
election and those that used it to deny
an American citizen quarter-page of his
constitutional rights and use those
Russian lies to commit a fraud again and
again and again four separate times on
the FISA Court to spy on the Trump
campaign now thankfully our calls for
truth and justice are all about to be
answered after Muller madness hysteria
and breathless reporting tomorrow begins
to die down and it
this is what's coming next in the coming
days months weeks there is a complete
avalanche of truth that will start to
cascade down on all of the deep state
bad actors the corrupt media the
Democratic Party all the people missing
in action in what is the biggest abuse
of power corruption scandal in American
history we're talking about criminal
referrals coming from congressman Devin
Nunez more criminal referrals we expect
from the Horowitz report his report on
the FISA investigation committing fraud
to FISA Court judges they knowingly lied
to those judges and let's not forget the
uber investigation on leaking by these
officials the 302s conversations
Christopher Steele Bruce or the
applications the FISA applications
themselves especially the last one I'm
told pages 10 through 12 17 to 34 then
we'll get the gang of eight information
what did the FBI know when did they know
it we might get information on
Christopher steel from a court in
Florida and this is very important AG
bars investigation into spying they
spied on the Trump campaign it happened
now these investigations will bring a
lot of bad actors to justice the
consequences will be steep and to date
we have been right about everything that
has transpired surrounding the Deep
States abuse of power the witch hunt
into President Trump and tomorrow you
will see the last mass hysteria freak
out on this topic there'll be another
one and it will pass now this week I
nearly had a heart attack why well calm
this from the Washington Post they
didn't they get a Pulitzer like the New
York Times for their hoax coverage he
had to courage to admit in an article
titled look at this Fox News has been
right all along
Gary Abernathy I'm worried for his job
tonight
he writes quote Fox News hosts like
Tucker Carlson Laura Ingraham and
especially Sean Hannity have been
slammed for spending nearly two years
clamoring for an investigation of the
investigators it would behoove serious
journalists to put aside their political
biases and delve into a story that might
actually be worthy of Watergate
comparisons even if it includes the pain
admission that fox news has been right
all along
Wow imagine that talk-show host right
again we've listed all the times we've
been right and they've been wrong you
know I am a talk-show host
I sometimes report straight news I have
hundreds of hours of coverage we've done
investigative reporting like vetting
Obama we have for the last two years
we also offer strong opinions I don't
hide it sometimes we talk about sports
culture it even laughs and have fun like
if you're a talk show host you like to
hold newspaper you remember the press
the Free Press in America and every news
division in this country was wrong
except I will say people in our news
division like Catherine Herridge and
Henry I'm not going to name everybody we
had we even had our own sources I had my
own sources and by the way I will
protect them to the grave and by the way
I hope mr. Abernathy I hope you don't
get fired the truth actually got out in
the Washington Post only one small part
of our promise to hold the deep state
accountable the investigations taking
place right now in the DOJ and Congress
are the only thing standing in the way
of this country becoming a Banana
Republic
if we don't investigate investigators
lock up the bad actors this country will
be over as we know it all must be held
to account including those who rigged
Hillary's probe process persecuted from
spied on a political campaign trying to
rig a presidential election attempted a
deep state coup on a duly elected
President of the United States if
justice is not served say goodbye to our
democratic republic say goodbye to your
freedoms you can say goodbye to your
precious rights endowed by our
Constitution and create tor God we must
protect also the 99.9% of good people in
the FBI in the telogen skom unity that
protect the innocent people here and
around the globe premier agencies around
the world it's only 1% that did wrong we
either get equal justice that we deserve
we'll have no country